Well thank you [inaudible] for having me.
Thank you,
Google for having me.
Thank you for coming.
Lean out.
As I said,
our official pub date is September 3rd.
Uh,
so this is really getting an early start and I think it's Kinda Rad that Google
had me here considering what the book is about.
Uh,
so I've called this conversation,
leaning out Google,
lean out and here's my information.
Uh,
I'm extremely friendly as Josh and Co's can attest too.
They've known me since college.
Uh,
and now you know me.
So feel free to stay in touch with me on Twitter.
And this is a little about me.
I'm the editor of this book,
lean out and I'm also organizing a security conference in New York and I run a
privacy company.
If you decide you want more books,
they're on or books or Amazon or just yell at me on Twitter.
So it's pretty Rad that you invited me here today considering what this book is
about.
Uh,
I told a friend that I was invited and he said,
well,
they haven't read your book.
I implying of course,
if,
if you knew what I was doing,
you would not have me here.
But,
um,
I actually think that's not true.
I think it's a reflection of what Google's about that,
that you're welcoming me in to have this conversation.
Uh,
so one of the chapters in this book is Ericka Joy.
She published this first on medium and agreed to let us republish it,
which I was very grateful for.
It's called the other side of diversity.
And it's about,
among other things,
her negative experiences as a black woman at Google.
So,
you know,
that's real,
that's a thing that happens.
But I'm optimistic about Google and,
or shall I say Alphabet Inc.
I see a face palm in the front row.
I'm all for it.
I mean,
this way they can spin things out and avoid lawsuits between divisions.
It's,
it's smart.
Um,
I was at the lesbians who Tech Event and I saw Megan Smith and I just became
such a fan girl,
not only for Smith,
but for Google's efforts towards gender inclusion and people of color.
Megan Smith is saying here in this Jif that the importance of diversity,
that the problems we face as humanity,
I mean she's thinking really big,
that they're so big that we need to activate everyone.
We need everyone involved because how else are we going to solve the world's
deepest problems?
And here she was at the helm at Google and she spoke at the lesbians who tech
event about the efforts Google had made to attract and hire women.
And,
and I believe that she was very sincere.
So I know that within Google these efforts have been made and that they're real.
And so I come here today,
you know,
all friendly,
like not hostile despite what's in this book.
I really appreciate that Google's a really big company and that you've brought
in some of the best thinkers on this and that there are people here who are
trying hard.
And so that's the spirit that I want to have this conversation today,
that you know,
we're all here.
We want to make this better,
we're going to acknowledge what's wrong.
And also acknowledge that Google has a lot of potential to be part of making
things better.
Uh,
so to start,
uh,
first,
a lot of feminists have me blocked on Twitter.
So you know,
I may be kind of a surprising person for you today and I have doubts about the
efforts to recruit women and underrepresented groups.
That's because women Lgbtq and people of Color in my network are struggling to
be funded and promoted and report sometimes shocking harassment.
So I worry about bringing in new people before we figured out how to retain and
advance the people who were here at the same time.
I just heard Megan Smith speak about how it's so urgent that we bring in
everyone.
And so all of these things are here and real and,
and it's really hard.
Part of what
lean out does is it describes the shape of the problem as many of us experience
it.
But it's really just a start.
I'm still figuring out what the solution looks like and that's one reason why
I'll want to open this up pretty quickly.
And so a conversational format because I think a lot of us are trying to figure
out what those solutions look like.
But kind of understanding the shape of the problem is a really good start.
So recruitment a company like Google doing recruitment doesn't necessarily mean
hiring or promotion.
Uh,
and this is all the more true when it's things like teaching kindergartners how
to Code,
right?
Like all that does is increase the possibility of applicants that a company like
Google might bring in.
But it doesn't come with any responsibility to actually support funds or promote
all of those people who now know how to code.
It doesn't mean going to get jobs or they're going to get funded.
Uh,
so that's one of my reservations.
Being a qualified woman does not necessarily lead to being hired,
promoted,
funded,
or respected or treated well once you land somewhere,
which is part of the herd problem that we're figuring out now.
Something else they'll go into,
cause I'd like to read a little bit from lean out is that I love all the
additional opportunities and resources that are coming now with recruitment
efforts for women.
But I just want to take a lot of care that we don't say that women need special
programs.
I've never felt that I needed something special to be interested in tech.
And I think that's true for many women and people of color and Lgbtq.
I'll focus specifically on women,
but uh,
in lean out and in this preface now really we're talking more broadly about all
underrepresented groups.
I think it's not that women need special programs,
so we just need,
you know,
respect.
And
so how well I'll get into it to be very clear.
Women,
Lgbtq and people of color are already here and we are already awesome.
So feel indulge me.
I'm going to read a little bit from the chapter that I wrote and then open this
up and we'll all,
we'll see what you have to say and what your questions are.
That's good with everyone.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
My chapter is called the pipeline isn't the problem,
the pipeline problem and narrative that states that the reason big tech
companies have poor track record for hiring and promoting women is because there
are too few women interested in or skilled in stem.
The idea that tech has a pipeline problem,
one that can be solved by teaching five year old girls to code infuriates me.
It's awkward to say,
so I need to tread carefully here lest I be accused of bad feminism.
I can see the headline now,
lady boss against stem education for girls also secretly hates puppies.
I don't hate puppies but I'm allergic.
So you know,
I am of course in favor of teaching girls to code and it is true that there are
more men than women applying for jobs and programs in Silicon Valley.
But the reason why we don't have more women in tech is not because of a lack of
stem education.
It's because too many high profile and influential individuals and subcultures
within the tech industry have ignored or outright mistreated women,
applicants and employees.
To be succinct,
the problem isn't women.
It's tough culture.
That's the issue that needs to be addressed.
The work that I aim to do here is clarifying the nature of the women in tech
problem to the extent that we agree something is wrong.
The women who work in tech agree that the problem is harassment,
discrimination and a generally hostile work environment.
Many sight difficulties being hired,
promoted or getting funding.
An overwhelming number of the highest profile technology companies have had a
sexual harassment scandal that has made headlines many within the next,
the last year.
It is unsurprising that these companies have difficulties hiring women.
In 2012 I was told by a senior manager at Youtube that I was not qualified for
Google.
Some context here is that I had actually been in SAP since 1997 and I had a lot
of technology jobs.
I was told Google only hires the best.
That's you guys.
Despite spending many days add youtube,
been at Google.
I was never recruited.
I would go there to visit my housemate,
my friends,
or to meet with business contacts I did in lunch at the youtube HQ,
Google,
Cambridge and Google mountain view.
There was a time when I was quite the Google fan girl.
I would have loved to have worked on Google plus back when that product was
still promising.
I am known for having a lot of self confidence.
Claire Cane Miller of the New York Times described me as having entrepreneurial
Breo.
I do not have a confidence problem,
but I definitely integrated the idea that I would not be hired at Google.
In retrospect,
I may have had opportunities if I had fought for them,
but Google is espousing the idea that women are nowhere to be found.
I was on campus frequently and what have been an easy recruit.
Google and every other big tech company can't ask for much more than for
potential female hires to walk right onto campus.
As I did frequently in 2011 and 2012 I have brilliant female friends who have
applied for roles at Google and other tech companies and I've also been
rejected.
I am very curious to understand why.
Then I go on,
so let's stop saying that women aren't here or that they aren't skilled.
Let's instead look at why we're not seeing hiring,
promoting funding,
respecting the women who are as Ali or Ramen tweeted at the lesbians who Tech
Conference.
I believe the best way to hire women and people of color is to hire them.
Sometimes.
I think it really is that simple.
The best way to hire more women is to hire them.
We were already here and we are already awesome.
Thank you.
So I think that's enough to open things up.
Um,
let's say questions and,
and take it from there.
Can you hear me?
I see costs getting a mic.
This movie.
Hi.
I was hoping for a clarification when you said that we're already here.
We're already awesome.
Um,
so the criticism was that big tech companies aren't hiring.
One of the criticisms was one of the big tech companies aren't hiring women
applicants who are already there.
Um,
is that because there's an implicit bias?
Is it because they're not sort of choosing to hire more women?
Um,
so,
so what do you need the root causes?
If there's women who are here who are awesome,
who can be hired and tech companies or at least saying they want more women,
where's the gap between the two?
Like what is the cause of that not,
and I'm not being hired.
I think we're all trying to understand that right now.
And I give Google a lot of credit.
It's my belief that many of the upper management in Google are also working on
this.
Uh,
so with that in mind,
I think some of it is not seeing the potential applicants.
Uh,
I'll use myself as an example.
I'm never recruited ever,
maybe like once every 60 days and I fairly prominent.
So companies are saying they can't find women,
but are they actually really looking?
Uh,
so I think that's the first part.
Like women are hearing the ecosystem,
but we're not necessarily showing up where you're hoping to find us.
For example,
I'm part of a female founders group.
There are a ton of women there.
Many of them would probably be really happy to get a job at Google.
Um,
right now I'm pretty busy.
I have this book out,
have a conference,
I have a company,
but six months ago that was not the case in anyone could have hired me and I
begged my friends to hire me as my startup was shutting down and my friend hired
me.
Uh,
and that was great,
but it goes to show that we're here and we're not necessarily being seen by the
companies.
I mean,
one thing I'll point out is that recruiters will often ask,
who do you know?
Right?
Who can we go and talk to and recruit?
And if the people that you know are very much like you,
then that's going to be a problem,
right?
Like there's network effects,
which is one small part.
That's a really important point.
And that's often cited when you have organizations that are led by a white men
and many of the employees,
white men,
and then they're asked to go recruit their friends.
They're going to go and recruit people from their network.
Uh,
so we have this problem of how do we get outside our network and find all these
other people who are going to think differently.
Uh,
and I think that's actually very important.
I'm not a social justice warrior.
That's not the police I'm coming from.
I mean,
I care about that a lot,
but I'm worried about how we're going to solve all these problems without
bringing in everyone's perspectives.
So I'm in my mid thirties,
and I'd been in technology about as long as you have through the back door and I
feel like I'm entering or I read that I'm entering,
uh,
the big washout period for women in technology and looking around.
I actually don't see many women much older than me and I'm curious
a few,
and you guys were very gracious.
Thank you.
Um,
but I,
I really do wonder,
like,
it's not just the pipeline issue.
It's not that the women are here,
it's also that women are choosing to leave technology companies.
Uh,
and in my own experience,
I think that culture actually does have a lot to do with that.
The higher you get,
the more the Duke's come out,
the more aggressive and assertive,
the more you really can't cry,
you know,
like,
what do you think about that mid career female technology path?
I think it's not only for women,
but that there's this fetishization of youth.
Now I'm a tail mentor.
I am very,
very excited that young people are being given the opportunities they are,
that they're being taken seriously.
And I love the work being done by innovative young people.
Um,
but I also love the work done by older people.
We do a different kind of work in general.
Uh,
the people involved with me and my company are all older than me.
We're building an enterprise security company.
We're building stuff that needs to scale,
that cannot fail the counter,
have vulnerabilities that you can't build over a hackathon weekend.
And
sometimes older people in our ecosystem aren't valued as much as I'd like to see
them being valued.
And that's true for men and women.
But these issues become exacerbated for women because we're already facing so
much.
Yeah.
Just to put a stat on that,
I believe I saw something about the dropout rate for women after 10 years and
in,
in tech is about 50%.
Um,
but agreed.
since I'm in that group,
uh,
it's wonderful to be,
you know,
there was all the sexism that one had to deal with and now it's,
oh,
ages and plus x Simpson.
Awesome.
Um,
uh,
I have a question about just the title of your book.
The title,
you know,
lean out is invoking obviously a reference Sheryl Sandberg's
book.
And I was,
I,
I was wondering,
um,
in what,
how has your message directly addressing her message?
Not as much as you would want.
Kind of wondering what,
I didn't hear as much of it here and I was wondering in what you've talked about
so far and I was wondering whether there was more in the,
well,
there is actually,
and it comes through when you read the book as a collection.
Uh,
so I'm very grateful to Sheryl Sandberg.
I think that she's been a trailblazer for women in tech and in business.
It was really impactful when her book came out to see someone of her stature
taking on feminism as an issue,
encouraging women to be leaders and we needed that.
And that's why this book has been a best seller since it launched,
but three years later leanin just isn't enough and it doesn't speak to all of
us.
What lean out does that I'm so proud of is it brings together so many different
voices from so many different people and like I'm not on the cover.
The book is about,
it's an effort to encapsulate the experiences of as many people as possible in
the industry and to speak to what it's like to be someone who isn't white and
overeducated and reasonably pretty.
And uh,
you know,
I'm too close to that demographic,
which is why there's so many collaborators in this text and it speaks to,
you know,
being a person of color,
being Lgbtq,
being in gaming.
And there's something really powerful about that.
I think we all see that,
that it's time not only for more voices to be heard,
but for more approaches.
Right?
Like one of the chapters in lean out talks about not drinking the Koolaid and
just one approach really doesn't fit all.
I was just on Twitter and Sam Altman was giving advice and it was like mad,
like this works for the 20 people who you're mentoring right now and just all
those of us who don't,
who aren't fitting into that mold.
Like we need to start doing things our way.
And the book hints at that and explores that in different chapters.
Uh,
I think one example I like to give is how it's harder for women and people of
color to get really early stage funding.
You know,
it's always hard to get early stage funding.
I have a lot of white guys coming to me and they're like,
Alyssa,
can you help me?
You know,
so like the ecosystems hard on a lot of people right now,
but it's,
it's like almost impossible for women and people of Color.
Uh,
so Melanie Moore,
his advice in the book and I met going,
that is to build a business with customers.
You know,
we'll try and like go around these obstacles,
try and find ways to,
you know,
silicon valley,
is it working for you?
We need to figure out another way.
Maybe it means building,
you know,
a lifestyle business,
but maybe that shouldn't be stigmatized.
You know,
silicon valley VC firms are not giving a return back to their investors.
A startups are failing.
Like the default is that VC firms and startups fail.
So it's time that we stop stigmatizing these like profitable,
stable lifestyle companies with people who are actually building businesses with
real customers.
There's a very good,
um,
op Ed piece in the New York Times today about the,
what the gender gap in pay.
And I'm,
one of the things that it points out is that the UK now requires large companies
to publish their gender gap figures.
When price Waterhouse coopers in the UK did this,
they discovered that almost the entire pay gap was due to lack of women in
higher positions.
And so they studied it and they found out that indeed there was a serious
promotion problem.
Just backing up your,
your point,
uh,
now,
I know that Google has internally studied promotions in the last few years.
I don't,
it's been a while since I looked at those figures.
I don't remember what the conclusion was.
I don't remember that there was a huge gap and promotion rates,
but I may be totally misremembering.
Maybe other people do.
Let me,
so that would be one thing if somebody would answer,
but I,
two of the really common reasons that are now cited for this problem,
um,
basically put the onus on women.
One is that women take more time off than men of course,
to have families and so forth.
And just in general,
once they have families are not willing to work the crazy hours that men are
because they want to devote more time to their families.
And as a result of this,
they don't get promoted.
The other thing that people often say is that women are simply not aggressive
enough in pursuing both promotion and higher salaries.
They don't ask for them.
And when they do ask,
they don't ask for as much as men do.
So I'd be really interested in your response to those two things,
which one now sees just about everywhere sited as the two of the really main
reasons.
So I,
I understand how people could look at that data and say,
well,
it's fair,
but I actually think that it's bs because you have a system that was created by
men for men and now women are coming in.
And the thing is men are now saying they want women here.
Whether that's because of political and social pressure or because they actually
see the of women in the workplace.
Nonetheless,
we have the leadership at companies saying,
we want women here in our companies.
We want to retain them and we want to promote them.
So we need to find ways to do that without placing all of the onus on women.
And we know that women negotiate differently than men.
Why is our system for promotions based on this set up that makes sense for men
and not for women?
When women are now coming in the workforce and we're saying that we want to
integrate them in a meaning full way,
I think that's the lens that's useful to look at.
This,
uh,
like yes,
women aren't playing the game the way men are expecting them to,
but if we want women to be at our companies and stay and be happy and be
promoted,
that's on all of us to figure out how we changed things.
And,
and that's part of what lean out means to me.
You know,
lean in was saying,
all right women,
like this is how you behave like mad to get ahead and get that seat in the
boardroom.
And that's,
that was a step forward.
But now it's time.
Now that men are saying they want women here,
now it's time to say,
how does the workplace accommodate women?
How do men stirred to change their behaviors to welcome us here?
That's the conversation I want us to start having.
And it's hard
in the back.
Yeah.
One thing that you brought up did,
it took me a while to internalize is when you said funding,
uh,
because I have friends in academia and so originally I thought you were talking
about academic funding,
but I believe you're talking about things like VC funding.
Is that correct?
Right.
I'm talking,
I'm coming from the startup community and I have a bias in my language towards
that.
I'm very interested in academia,
but I don't know much about it.
Yeah.
And then,
yeah,
we just came from two different worlds and now I'm getting it.
And it's interesting because I wonder to what extent that that feature of the
tech world right now,
the fact that the kind of one of the images of the very,
very successful person in our world is,
is,
is someone who has come up with an idea,
gone in front of investors,
said,
here's my idea.
Do you believe in my idea?
Do you believe in me to execute that idea?
And that's,
you know,
the startup founder,
as you know,
there are many other fields of business in which that is not nearly as prevalent
a model.
You know,
someone might,
many more people in that field of business might be someone who came up through
the ranks in a very established company and that's seen as being one very valid
way of being successful.
I'm curious whether that,
you know,
if the dynamics of that you think are somewhat holding tech back compared to
other fields of business,
that feature of,
of the economics of the business?
I think tech is doing great actually.
I think that we're seeing tremendous innovation in technology.
Uh,
people like Vivek Wadhwa critique technology for not necessarily focusing on
important enough problems.
And I think there's something to be said for that.
But uh,
of all the industries you look at technology and the pace of innovation is just
incredible.
And I look in my own life and like the quality of my own life has improved so
much due to technology just in the last few years and much of that technology
has come out of silicon valley.
So as much as I'll stand here and criticize some aspects,
I do think there's something there that's working really well.
What I worry about with funding is how much of that ends up being about
camaraderie or believing in someone.
And I'll give an example that I may regret later given that this is a live feed,
but I think it's important.
Uh,
I was fundraising last year with my cofounder pacs Dickenson and we had between
10 and 20% week over week traction with the teenage market.
We were able to go into a school and get any target group off snapchat using US
instead.
Uh,
so we had a lot going for us.
Um,
but we have problems as well.
Uh,
some of which are pretty well known.
What's interesting is the VC response,
some of the feedback I've gotten was that Alyssa is too confident.
She gave two high evaluation.
The other feedback is Alissa is not confidence enough.
So there was this kind of intense scrutiny around my confidence level and I'm
not sure if that's gendered or not.
That's part of the problem we deal with.
That's why it's helpful for us to have these kinds of conversations,
talk on social media,
discover if there's a commonality of gender is that commonality and a lot of
experiences people are having.
But I suspect that my gender may have had something to do with that.
Why was everyone so focused on my confidence level?
We have really great traction.
Yeah.
So I also have a question which is one thing that I've heard a lot in the past
couple of years is that part of the problem with recruiting women who are
already here and able to code is that the very small number of women in the
company is part of the problem.
And it's also part of the problem for retention.
That is those who are already in the company are more likely to leave because of
the culture in which are very
few women.
So I wonder what you think about the interplay between retention and recruiting
and pipeline and how maybe each one of them affects the other.
That's interesting.
I've been hearing a lot from women involved in diversity outreach efforts within
their own companies and it seems to be very draining for them.
I don't know anything about this.
Uh,
I kind of became like this accidental feminist and like carry on Manal like
obviously like I'm in it.
But when I started glimpse with packs,
we just hired the people who we could,
we are grateful that we could hire anyone at the time.
And we hired a bunch of white boys because that's who we knew and that's who
worked for us.
And we weren't thinking about it very hard.
Uh,
and so I actually have never been in that corporate setting where someone's
asked me to take this on.
But,
uh,
I think that companies need to be very aware that,
women,
feminists,
civil rights activists,
they consider that to be unpaid emotional work and,
and are not necessarily happy about it.
I think the companies look at it as a favor.
Like I,
uh,
like here we are at this big tech company and we're going to care about the
thing you care about.
So here go do 20 hours worth of work.
Um,
I think,
I think if the companies made it like a really important position in the company
and really well paid and,
uh,
you know,
I think if there was more benefit and prestige and tangible reward attached to
doing that work,
then that would help retain the women who are in the company and bring in New
People.
Um,
but we could talk about this all day.
It's a really,
really hard problem.
And I suspect that those of you who are actually here at Google probably have
more insight than I do,
although I'm studying this pretty hard
in the back.
So I have two questions,
but I'll stick with one for now.
Um,
I'm a proud Harvey Mudd alumni and daily love.
Yes.
Um,
they've done a bunch of stuff that's been incredibly successful in getting women
into computer science by making small changes.
And I've talked with them a little bit about their theories about why it works
and there's some interesting stuff there.
Um,
and they've also done a whole bunch,
um,
even more recently to bring in underrepresented minorities.
And like one of the things that change the average acceptance rate from below
the overall mud acceptance rate to higher than that was just having faculty,
which like self organized on a mailing list,
call every accepted student and say,
hey,
we like you and we would like you to be here.
Um,
and that small change made a big effect in,
and now the like,
the,
the new student rate is much improved and like it,
it makes a big difference on campus.
Do you have thoughts on things that tech companies can actually do that might
make similar like substantial changes?
I think that's right.
I have a friend who,
uh,
did work at Google and actually she still works at Google.
She's been very successful here.
And,
uh,
Facebook tried to steal her away,
and Sheryl Sandberg herself called her on the phone and encouraged her to lean
in and said like,
we want you here,
I want you here.
And that was very meaningful.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this friend of mine ended up staying at Google,
but she's also deeply wanted here and she knows that.
I think there's something really powerful about knowing that a place wants to.
Uh,
I recently joined the mock 37 cyber security accelerator.
I don't know how much I'll have,
you know,
about the infosec industry,
but especially in DC,
it's not only why the mail,
it's white and male and military.
So it's not a place that I would have thought is net,
like naturally my place.
But I knew that they really wanted me.
And then when I got there,
it was really nice.
Uh,
and we were part of the first class of women and there was,
you know,
some learning for everyone around that,
but I didn't care that,
you know,
this program was run by white men.
Most of the alumni and the connections were white men who was like,
we're all hackers.
We have that in common and they want me and I talk about that in the book too
and lean out and you know,
everyone was here.
It gets a free coffee so you can read it.
When I got into computer science it's because they wanted me,
you know,
that that was very impactful.
I was getting recruited left and right.
The computer science department was really warm and friendly.
Everyone wanted to teach me how to code and I think that has a lot to do with
where I am now in tech where like I love it and all of this like sexism just
feel so foreign to me.
Like it's this thing that's happened that I can't even believe happen because
when I got into technology that that was not my experience at all.
And
I think that that's a big step for us to let people know that they're wanted.
Maybe one followup thing is that I think a lot of people at Google Austin feel
imposter syndrome and I think that there's,
there's gendered aspects to that in general.
But I also think there's this,
am I really good enough and here I am doing this hiring and what I passed this
hiring interview can,
can lead to doubt about whether you're really qualified in general and with that
am I really wanted or would somebody else be better?
Which I don't think is necessarily only gendered,
but I think it plays into the where else are you getting signals about being
wanted,
right.
And,
and it's been talked about very widely,
but it's worth reiterating here that women will only apply for a job if they're
like super qualified.
Whereas men will apply.
Like they'll just apply and I'm trying to learn that lesson myself and I mean I
should have just applied to Google plus one.
I thought that was like the most badass thing ever.
And I did it because I didn't because I didn't think I didn't as confident as I
am,
I didn't have it.
So when we do our,
when we do our recruitment process,
we need to know that if we actually really want women,
we need to recruit for
women.
I think there's an also is an aspect of if there's a culture of a leadism,
you have to actually tell people at some point you're okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
Like you're here,
you're one of us,
you know,
for better or worse.
And you're not the only one who's figuring out your job.
Any other questions?
Yes.
This isn't a question so much as to respond to your point about what small
concrete actions could be taken.
I just wanted to share something that I know my previous company did.
Um,
they're called ThoughtWorks and they actually do pretty well in terms of hiring
women and minorities.
And one thing they do in the interview process is for one,
they always make sure there are two people interview and they also treat certain
things like smells.
When an interviewer says,
I don't think they're going to fit in,
or I don't think they're like me,
they immediately throw that out because that will just encourage a company that
has certain culture to keep hiring people who are similar than them.
And it's a very natural human thing to do.
But they explicitly make sure that as part of the interview process,
they don't want that to factor in.
Just to tie together these two comments,
um,
about the rate of promotion at Google.
So,
uh,
when they did the study,
they found that at every level,
um,
that as you go up,
the number of women at that level have,
um,
and so what did you get to a certain level?
They're very,
the percentage of women is very low.
Um,
and that is the truth.
That's the case in Cambridge as well as elsewhere.
Uh,
and when they did that study,
uh,
several years ago that concluded,
the reason they noticed that when women asked,
when the women went up for promotion,
they were promoted at the same rate as their male counterparts,
but they were,
um,
going up for promotion,
trying to go up for promotion half as often.
Um,
and the sad part about that was the conclusion was that women weren't trying to
get promoted.
Uh,
and there were many of us who I think at the time were upset about that because
usually people go up for promotion when they get a signal from their boss at
that that's going to go through.
Um,
and,
you know,
so there are signals about feeling wanted,
about feeling accepted that maybe we're not getting through or simply the bosses
were not telling the,
the,
the were not telling,
indicating,
uh,
beforehand.
Well,
I think you should try to go up.
I think that's right.
And that there's just,
there are so many elephants in the room.
There's so much that we don't talk about.
Uh,
I was in a conversation and a closed Facebook group recently that delved into
some of the concerns that hiring managers have about women.
Uh,
and in this case,
some of those interviewers and hiring managers had made their concerns explicit
without realizing they were expressing illegal or like just kind of offensive
things,
including trying to assess out if,
you know,
the women were about to make babies,
are interested in making babies and just all the presumption that women,
uh,
after a certain age,
that age being I guess,
I don't know,
17,
um,
are,
are going to at some point drop their careers and go and make babies.
Uh,
and that's very frustrating for the women who feel that by showing up to
interview or by showing up to ask for capital,
they're saying that they're in it,
you know,
and,
and that's my feeling.
Like if I show up and I said,
I'm going to do it,
I want you to take that at face value.
So I worry about that with some of these issues that the hiring managers may
assume,
like there may be both implicit and explicit bias there.
Uh,
and also if I may and had the stage so I can,
uh,
women will say that they're leaving for family or for babies or for all these
reasons.
And that's not always why.
And I say this as someone who has leaned out and left so many times and it's
only now that I'm more self aware and that I'm aware of these issues in the
industry that I can look back and say,
Oh yeah,
you know,
that time that I left the country,
like I quit my job and left the country.
It's because I felt like I'd run out of options at my current company.
I didn't understand how I could improve my career.
Back in 2005,
I was thinking maybe Grad school,
but that felt very amorphous and I ended up in ex pat and then I ended up
married and like,
you know,
years of adventures and,
and,
and why did that happen?
It happened because like what I really wanted was to be a vice president at
everyday health.
I didn't know how to get there.
I mean,
now I do,
I don't plan to leave.
I'm pretty busy.
But that's one reason,
right?
Like women are just,
and I see heads nodding like women just,
they don't want to leave but they,
they don't want,
they can't stay.
The other reason is the real elephant in the room and it's even harder to talk
about,
which is women end up sometimes with very intense harassment.
My book describes a woman who's describing rape at work.
Um,
the,
the things that people experience sometimes are deeply traumatic and you can't
talk about it,
you know,
it doesn't,
I think it's really important to read Katie Levinson's article on whistle
blowing if you can.
Sometimes women can't talk about what happened to them because it's not going to
help them personally and they're already struggling to deal with what's happened
to them.
They're not in a position to be an activist or to be a martyr.
They need to get on with their lives and figure things out.
And so when we assume that women are leaving to make babies,
I just don't think that's the reason why a lot of women are leaving.
Yes,
women leave for family,
but we often can't talk about why we left.
I would just like to point out the Vic Gundotra is supposedly spending time with
his family right now and uh,
Lucy made this wonderful snarky point right behind me a second ago that when men
leave to say they're spending time with their families,
especially if they have just led the company through a giant multi year
disaster,
we all roll our eyes like how sure you are.
But if a woman says it,
for some reason we believe her and like what the fuck's up with that?
Yeah.
Women,
it's just the easy thing to say.
You can't say I'm leaving because,
and then fill in the blank with something that would like be a Gawker headline.
No one wants that for themselves.
You know,
it's just an anecdote.
I had my babies and I've made it clear to every single manager since then that
no two is enough.
Um,
and at my last company,
I made it explicit,
extraordinarily explicit,
every single review that I was looking for leadership and my CEO told me that he
did not think of me as a leader.
Please notice the x company part of that.
Right.
But it would have been way easier,
so much less conflict,
so much simpler for me to either dodge hide,
you know,
use an excuse,
stay low,
hide my head,
just keep working hard and wait to be noticed.
Um,
and I really started to feel like my point,
it was actually less about sexism than mid career ism where you're looking for
those first jobs as a manager,
as a leader,
as a person in the company.
Other people look to for answers and uh,
the people above you say,
I'm sorry,
I just,
I don't think of you like that
and that is why I'm a startup founder,
but I would be very interested in figuring out and understanding a way for
people to make that happen in corporate life.
Uh,
and if anyone has ideas,
I would love to hear them.
I have,
I'm not sure if it's a question or an observation,
but regarding the,
the
rates of promotion at Google,
Google is a little weird and that in most companies,
um,
you know,
a manager says,
Hey,
I think you could do it,
this other rule and they promote you and then you do it.
And Google kind of looks to you to have started working above your level already
and there could very well be gendered barriers to doing that,
but they might be very different from the kind that block promotion at other
companies.
It may be,
maybe it's a reluctance to work above your level when you haven't been blessed.
Maybe it's resistance from other people to taking your leadership when you
haven't been promoted yet.
Maybe it's lack of encouragement.
I don't know what it is.
That is really interesting.
I want to speak to that really briefly because in this one particular way,
I'm a very stereotypical woman so I can speak to the like totally girly side.
And I've been at Google for eight years now and I've been uh,
eventually through two promotions and I am one of those people who won't apply
for the job unless they have every single bullet point.
And I also will not go for the promotion until I have every single bullet point.
And for that reason I think it's actually kind of Nice that Google lets you work
at that level before you take the title.
Because I would not go up for the title until I had actually done those things
because I would say I don't know if I will try those things and fail.
So I actually think it's a very also feminine style friendly way to do it that
Google is doing
well.
I'm glad to hear that and I'm really optimistic about what women are going to
build.
That's part of the message that I hope will come through with lean out is that
it's really hard relying on systems that are already made that other people
made.
I think that some of the change that we're going to see in silicon valley is
going to come from just creating our own institution.
And making new ways to do things.
And I think it's time for that.
Yeah.
Well,
just to expand on that,
how much of the problem is just a pervasive culture that rewards individualism
and aggression?
Um,
for example,
um,
you know,
when,
uh,
people in the whole tech industry talk about the kind of person they want to
hire,
they often use the term rock star.
I hate that term.
I think it should be completely banished.
My associations with rock stars are almost completely negative and not the kind
of people that succeed or that you would want in your company.
Why can't we have such a system that promotes cooperation?
Um,
you know,
um,
the communication,
uh,
those are the kinds of things that I find most lacking among many of the males
that I work with.
And they're extremely important.
I mean,
that,
you know,
companies I think in that can promote those traits actually probably are more
successful than groups that don't it,
you know,
there's just so many aspects of this culture that every day promote the kind of
individualistic aggressive traits that stereotypical males have.
Let's take three more questions.
And yes,
100%.
I think that the best people on tech teams in my experience are the ones who are
like glue who somehow make everything go right.
Like yes,
there are those engineers who are 10 times better than everyone else.
I've seen that.
But in a team that's not always what it's about.
Uh,
and yeah,
100%.
I think we need to focus on collaboration.
And in my personal experience,
just for me personally,
the worst experiences I've had at companies have been with people whose egos
were threatened and who,
you know,
maybe we're threatened by me or threatened by someone else in the organization.
And uh,
I'm personally very interested in genuine meritocracy.
We just,
something that I don't see a lot of,
but I believe personally that if we found a way to have less like egocentric ego
threatens and competent people in teams,
that it would be better for women,
Lgbtq,
people of color.
I know it would be better for me when I come in somewhere as a strong woman and
I'm excited and I'm ready to like do my part and I'm being treated like an
expert.
Like there's that one person who's like,
she's figured out that I don't know what I'm doing.
Like,
look,
I'm not here to take you down,
but like
they get up in my grill and that's,
that's that lack of cooperation.
I think the best people are thinking how we move the whole team ahead.
Um,
switching gears a little bit,
I was hoping you could expand a little on your statement that the pipeline
problem is not the problem.
Um,
because I think it's hard to deny that it is a problem given that,
you know,
graduating classes of computer science majors have,
20% something like 20% women and 80% men.
Um,
and while I acknowledge all of the problems that,
that you are your pointing to as definitely genuine problems in the industry
itself.
Um,
yeah.
I could you just expand on that statement and what you think we could do better
as opposed to having,
um,
special programs for
yeah,
for sure.
Uh,
so part of what I'm really trying to show in my chapter the pipeline problem is
that we all agree there's a woman in tech problem or a man problem as Claire
Cane Miller put it.
Uh,
but it's a question of perspective,
right?
Uh,
the problems female founders and for female developers are different from the
problems faced by hiring managers.
Now hiring managers have a pipeline problem.
Hiring managers have a problem that social justice warriors are yelling at them
when they don't have enough women in their organizations and they need to bring
in more women.
But that's hard because the women are not showing up at the door.
I'm not that worried about that problem.
Like if the executives at Google have trouble hiring people and meeting,
they're like bottom line.
Like I'm a CEO,
I'm an adventure capitalists.
Like I'm down.
Like I understand why they care about that and I'm sympathetic.
Uh,
but I think that that's the problem of executives in the technology industry and
of shareholders.
And that's not who I'm worrying about right now.
The people who I'm worrying about or very specific demographics,
I'm worried about the women,
the people of Color,
the Lgbtq people who are already here,
who are already qualified and they're having like a nightmare of a time.
And those are the people I'm worried about.
So I worry about what happens if we're going to create more of that.
Like why do we want to bring in more people to an environment that isn't ready
for them?
And I worry,
okay,
so one of these organizations are trying to have one token woman,
they're already say 10 women for that job right now.
So you're going to bring in another 30 okay,
so now I have 39 unemployed women that that's what I'm worrying about.
I'm not saying that there isn't a problem of having women in these companies,
but I don't see how we bring more women into where we are now.
I think we need to make some changes and welcome women.
And the way to do that is to hire and funds and promote and respect women or a
here.
And then we'll go,
we'll be evangelist,
right?
Like if I go and I sell my company for $1 billion,
or like maybe we never sell,
we IPO and like are my friends,
right?
What maybe my friends go and they all get like fantastic jobs and they become
vps and they get funded.
What are we going to do?
We're going to recruit women to our companies.
We're going to become angel investors and fund them.
So that's the path that I think is interesting.
Like what if we just took the women are here and we empowered them and we gave
them resources and we made them really successful and we put them on the covers
of magazines.
All right.
Now,
like now you're organically going to get people saying,
Oh,
you know,
those are role models that I kind of relate to them.
So I think that you can solve that problem organically.
And,
um,
there's one more thing that I think is really interesting that we don't talk
about enough,
which is Steve Jobs,
Mark Zuckerberg,
all of these young white men faced a certain kind of discrimination when they
got started too.
They weren't taken seriously.
They did not look like what people thought and executive should look like.
Steve Jobs faced a lot of that and then they went and became super successful.
And now we all think that's what,
you know,
a founder looks like.
That's what an executive looks like.
He looks like a 19 year old Harvard dropout.
So I think that I'm going to venture capitalist,
I'm a free market feminist.
I think that if we
empower women and we put them on stage and we make them successful and they're
already awesome.
So I don't think that that takes a lot,
then all of this bias will go away on its own.
That's,
that's what I think.
So I have a somewhat related question.
Um,
why is technology the place where it's so bad?
and I think that there's maybe a couple of tight and things like there are a lot
of industries you can look at medicine,
you can look at law that have similar,
like they're very competitive,
the women weren't,
were excluded and then they,
they're now like they're in record numbers and there's these graphs where it's
like,
oh,
the,
the entrance looked like this.
And the women in cs sort of kind of dies off.
And a lot of the problems we talked about,
like we're talking about these sort of basic,
I don't want to say basic human nature things cause I,
but like societal structural problems that aren't necessarily unique to
technology.
Why is it that we're having so much more of a problem with this than other
industries are?
Or is it just because we're so visible because technology is booming right now?
Well,
visibility is certainly one aspect,
right?
Uh,
because you're seeing these big IPOs and there's so much money in silicon
valley.
What happens here is of tremendous interest.
And there's a lot of,
you know,
glamour and fantasy in the way that the media portrays silicon valley.
Although you know,
you know what coding actually looks like,
it's not that exciting.
Um,
so what are the reasons why we do have these cultural problems?
Because I do believe that technology does have problems that we're not seeing in
medicine.
In Law.
I have a friend who was a doctor and when she was a doctor,
she was given a lot of respect.
Then she became a startup founder and suddenly people are questioning her when
she was adopted,
she graduated law school,
I mean medical school.
So she had that credential.
Whereas with startups,
it's become very fashionable,
be the startup founder to be a programmer.
And so
we don't always take people at face value.
So that's one aspect.
And then there's no HR,
right?
You have these young companies and young founders,
they're being given millions of dollars or in some cases not so young.
Right?
You have a company like Google that's really grown up,
but they're to maintain this youthful culture and uh,
be HR is different.
I think that's a big piece of it has been,
uh,
intentionally trying to have,
you know,
agile environments.
And then you look at who our leaders have been.
You know,
if you read Paul Graham's writings,
he talks about how to have a successful company and he's saying that you need to
have your own culture and you need to be able to kind of square and be Raunchy.
So some of the thought leaders in Silicon Valley have in their own ways
encouraged an environment that,
you know,
you don't see that same kind of encouragement and medical school.
Uh,
yeah.
so I'm going to stick around for about 10 minutes and sign books.
I'm really very appreciative for Google to have this conversation.
I recently gave a talk against,
uh,
how the FBI and the government prosecutes hackers and I was really grateful to
be able to give that talk and publicize it.
And I'm still here,
I'm not in jail.
I kind of feel that way about giving the stock at Google,
like giving that talk about law enforcement reflects the freedom of speech we
have in America.
And giving this talk here at Google today reflects what I believe is a genuine
commitment at Google to make things better.
So please stay in touch with me if you're interested.
And one more thing,
you'll forgive the plug,
but you're all tech people and doing a security conference,
so y'all all are invited.
You can use friend of Alyssa for a discount and I don't know,
enjoy the book.
Stay inside.